okay I just got one question for folks
who claim that doctor who has gotten too
political in the last few years what
show were you watching before so and the
somehow still ongoing discussion in the
wake of Jodie Whittaker being cast as
the doctor there's an argument I still
see being cropped up and quite a fair
bit actually and by people with a
negative view about that casting and
other things that they consider to be
connected to it and the specific nuances
of exactly what people say will vary but
the gist of the argument goes like this
I'm not sexist but they did this for
political reasons and I don't like how
politics are being pushed in the show so
much these days
doctor who should not be political it
should just be fun space adventures not
as a rule of thumb I don't like to pick
out specific arguments that I see
happening in my comments sections and do
responses to them except in instances
where they keep cropping up over and
over and over again this happened before
when I had to do a video explaining why
Jodie Whittaker cast as the doctor is
not the same thing as the 2016 remake of
ghostbusters and this argument I keep
seeing happening over and over and over
again so now I do feel the need to
respond to it if for no other reason
then I am done responding to the
comments directly so this entire
argument whether being made genuinely or
being used as a smokescreen because
people don't want to own up to the fact
that they're just not comfortable with a
female doctor either way it doesn't
matter seems to be rooted in the idea
that doctor who used to be fun
adventures in space with a wacky
character who's kind of unpredictable
but in recent times has gotten all
political and that is a betrayal of what
the show used to be and this idea it
just doesn't hold water I mean when
exactly was this magical mythical time
when doctor who was not political I mean
if I look at when it comes up in my
comment sections people really seem to
zero in on series 10 because they bring
up bill and they bring up the episodes
like oxygen which was a very pointed
comment
capitalism so was it non-political
earlier and Capaldi's run before series
10 like when they had a prominent deaf
character in before the flood under the
lake two-parter or the very blatant
Muslim extremist parallel in the Saigon
invasion inversion or the clumsy
abortion metaphor that was killed the
moon or the exploration of Danny Pink's
PTSD no no obviously this this doesn't
work that's all political so okay
compile these era that can't be it
so what about earlier what about before
that what about Smith the days of the
eleventh Doctor with wacky hair and the
bowtie and things weren't so political
it's not like the show ever dealt with
things like the exploitation of animals
for the benefit of human society in the
beasts below or the use of apocalyptic
rhetoric and fear-mongering as a means
of controlling people in the Crimson
horror or dehumanization and personhood
as tackled in the rubble flesh and the
almost people quite possibly the most
Frank look at depression ever put on
film in any television show in Vincent
and the doctor or how the Cold War was
really about okay well you get the idea
all right so you know what me maybe it's
Moffat maybe Moffitt's the problem
Moffitt's where this doctor who got
totally political so let's go back to
the Russell T Davies era those were the
times no political messages and those
it's not like there was anything about
the danger of mob mentality and midnight
or dehumanization again in the doctor's
daughter it's not like the Planet of the
unit is about an exploited underclass or
that the villain and voyage of the
Damned is a caricature of a businessman
oh dear I think we found a pattern here
as well what else we got 42 is a hazards
of strip mining Natural Resources story
rise of the Cybermen the long game bad
wolf and the idiot slandered all tackled
the idea of mass media and entertainment
being used to placate a control a
population
turn left fires a Pompey waters of Mars
newer than the end of time all tackled
the idea of one person's value against
the greater good in some fashion or
another dialect the empty child and
arguably most of series one is dealing
with the
impact and unseen consequences of war
both on those who fought it and those
who were caught in the wake of it and
that's not even getting into the
casualness with which the show handled
interracial relationships and the
ominous sexual jack harkness but okay
okay look the show does not begin and
end in 2005 with new who we've got the
classic era so maybe it is the classic
era of Doctor Who that is back when
things were fun and not politically
charged oh hang on
monster peloton featured a mining strike
and was broadcast at a time when mining
strikes were happening in Britain its
precursor curse a peloton had the planet
dealing with whether or not to enter a
Galactic Federation which was again a
very topical in blatant allegory to the
then card debate as to whether or not
Britain should enter into the European
Economic Community the green death is a
pollution will kill us all story the Sun
makers is a vicious jab at taxation
written by a man who just gone through a
really bad tax experience the happiness
patrol features a parody of Margaret
Thatcher who was prime minister at the
time the Cybermen are all about
unchecked technological advancement at
the cost of humanity the epic the war
games is all about the value of
intervention is immerses the doctrine of
non-interference the demons features the
master masquerading as a religious
figure whose hypnotizing his followers
that's just the stuff that I could latch
on to and I don't have nearly the level
of knowledge on the classic era Doctor
Who that I have on knew who but surely
somewhere in the history of the show
there had to have been a time where it
wasn't delivering some political message
that must have been the case at one
point and to be fair it was and that
period of no of her political statements
lasted one story four episodes in about
100 minutes because the second story
ever done back in 1963 was the Daleks
and the Daleks are Nazis that's not
suppositions
that's not speculation that's not modern
reinterpretation Dalek creator Terry
nation was
very upfront and blatant about the
influence of Nazis on the creation of
the Daleks this was important to him to
the point that he made very certain in
genesis of the Daleks that when we see
the Cal edge which is the race that will
eventually be mutated and become the
Daleks before they're even in the metal
casing tanks they are in military garb
and behaving in a fashion that is
reminiscent of Nazis the doctors most
iconic foes there since the second story
ever broadcast were deliberately created
as a science fiction take on a real-life
military presence and political party so
the idea that doctor who has only
recently become politically charged is
simply without merit this show since the
beginning has repeatedly and
consistently made a point of telling
stories that reflect something going on
or that had gone on in the real world
was it all stories no but these are not
outliers it consistently came up over
and over and over again now if you want
to make the argument that you don't like
the political points that the show is
making lately that's fair enough but you
need to own up that that's what your
problem is
well you what you can't do is you can't
hide behind this idea that the show used
to not be political at all but now it is
and that's your problem
own up to the fact that it's not the
presence of the politics but the
specific political beliefs themselves
that you take issue with because this
show has always been a platform for
political ideas and if we are being
honest by and large progressive and
liberal leaning ideas now if you've been
a fan since childhood it is a distinct
possibility that when you first started
watching the show you didn't recognize
the political themes you didn't know
enough about the outside world and what
was going on in politics to draw the
connections and to see them I know that
discovers like that has been the case
for me for all sorts of stuff that I've
loved since I was a kid I revisit as
whoa there's this whole other thing
going on that I didn't even recognize
but not noticing them because you
weren't politically tuned enough to
recognize that connections doesn't mean
that they weren't there so stop making
the argument that the show used to not
be political and now is and that's what
you're hung up about if you don't like
the specific politics being pushed talk
about that make that argument if you
feel that the show used to handle
political topics with more grace and
subtlety than it currently does then
make that argument I don't personally
believe that's the case but I'm willing
to listen if that's the argument you're
prepared to make but to say that you
wish the show wasn't political at all is
to say you wish the show wasn't about
anything except spaceships and lasers
but if the show was stripped of its
political ideas it wouldn't even be
recognizable as Doctor Who so many
elements of what is fundamental to this
show to this character will be gone
there'd be no hoon
there be no Cybermen there'd be no
Daleks heck I would argue there wouldn't
even be a doctor not as we know the
character over the course of this show
the doctor has been many many things
including but not limited to an
interventionist a revolutionary an
anarchist and a pacifist these are all
political ideals these are who the
doctor is this is what the show is so
stop making an argument that simply has
no merit again if you want to tell me
that the specific political message is
being pushed you don't like tell me that
and we'll talk about that but to make
this claim that the show is pushing
politics when it didn't use to is simply
intellectually dishonest it's not true
don't make that argument because it has
no basis make the argument that you're
afraid to make the argument that
actually has you explain why the
specific political views being pushed
you are not okay with or why you are not
okay with the specific means in which
they're being pushed you can't argue
against their simple presence because
they've always been present
political views are in the core and then
the DNA of this show and that happens
since the beginning
dr. who is a political show it always
has been and it should continue to be so
that's my word on this particular topic
what are your thoughts whatever they are
if you can keep them civil please drop
them down the comments let's talk about
it don't forget to like subscribe check
me out on Twitter a council of geeks
give a listen to the council of geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]